[Musique]
célimène gaudieux la musau trois bassins
c'est désormais une sculpture à son
effigie dans la cour du collège qui
porte son goût cette figure féminine
poétesse chanteuse et musicienne a été
honoré ce 8 mars une esclave qui s'érige
en femme libre qui s'affranchit des
normes d'une société dominée par les
hommes tout un symbole pour les
collégiens présents ce jour-là
à traverser les mains de dieu nous
voulons valoriser la femme réunionnaise
celle qui malgré les difficultés de la
vie de tous les jours et bien se bat
pour
montré
au monde entier
à son quartier à sa famille que rien
n'était impossible
que même important
avec des difficultés
des handicaps et bien à force de courage
et bien enrichie en plus du buste de
célimène les élèves ont peint 13
portraits de femmes iconique dans le
cadre d'un projet initié par le
département intitulé la réunion terre
d'esclaves une galerie de portraits de
figures féminines qui se sont battus
dans divers domaines
choisir des femmes du monde entier qui
m'ont marqué toutes les matières qui
sont
enseignés dans ce collège donc en techno
à son physique chimie en a
e
à chaque groupe de profs a choisi a
débattu pour choisir une femme
remarquable qui peut
être le symbole de leur matière moi
perso je sors
un peu content et ému parce que
on a beaucoup de travail à faire sur
sur l'égalité hommes femmes et bien je
trouve aussi que chaque année chacun de
ces farines alpine wind et sport du
chante et ça m'a
pour clôturer la manifestation de
chansons écrites et mises en musique par
deborah boyer a été interprétée pour
rendre hommage à célimène gaudieux
[Musique]